okay let's uh let's see who else we can
talk to here real quick how about um
how about colin from oregon colin you're
on the air
hi can you hear me okay
yes i can mr pacman it's good to talk to
you again um i'd like to talk about
education if that's okay um okay
listening to this
this long conversations with everybody
i'm concerned what do you think american
education needs to do
to stop things like people buying into
conspiracy theories people absorbing
lies
what does the education system need to
do
to adjust our strategy because we're
kind of we're kind of too late now
we're going to have to do some
back pedaling a little bit but what can
we do yes how do we it depends on
different there's different problems
with different solutions there are some
school districts texas is famous for
this
where the curriculum
is just insanely politically biased and
it leads to people who come out of
school
um prone to all sorts of disastrous
beliefs because the the curriculum is
biased that's one problem and the
solution there is one
on the other hand there's lots of school
districts where
first of all the curriculum is just not
uh
rigorous enough in particular when it
comes to people understanding how to
think for themselves and so introducing
critical thinking
media literacy and probably philosophy
classes pretty early i would say
probably sixth or seventh grade if not
earlier
that would be
uh important and potentially a uh
solution and then third
there are parts of the country and parts
of culture and society where education
itself is seen as liberal indoctrination
and so no matter what it is that is in
the curriculum
if that's your belief going in you're
going to resist it and that's going to
also lead to ignorance and people like
you say that buy into stuff so there's a
lot of different problems and the
solutions are not exactly the same for
all of the problems it's really
unfortunate because i'm a teacher and
i'm really just caught in the middle of
all this masked unmasked stuff you know
sure the florida governor's saying you
can't wear masks and then my governor is
saying you have to and i live in an area
where everyone's up in arms and everyone
thinks that freedoms are being and i'm
just dude i just i want to teach my kids
right now to be better than this
right right no it's i can't even imagine
how difficult that is and unfortunately
you're a cog in the wheel in this sense
right so you can all you can do is the
best possible job with the kids sitting
in front of you i i uh
uh your your guest mr cousin said that
there was a memo that came out about
donald trump jr comparing educators to
the taliban and
what do i
look mr pacman i appreciate you thank
you for your time today
thank you appreciate it i i hear the
frustration in your voice there all
right thanks everybody who called in
that's going to do it for today we will
take calls again
very soon and i hope to hear from you
then